[Music]
thank you and hello today I'll be
talking to you about the case for
augmented reality on the web I'm Marley
raphson I'm a software engineer at
Google I'm on the WebEx our team and my
twitter handle is MP raphson I'd love to
hear your thoughts at the talk and just
continue the dialogue later so the two
things that we're talking about today
are the web and augmented reality so I
believe that the combination of these
two things is the whole is greater than
the sum of its parts situation so I
think that there's things that the web
will gain from augmented reality and
things that the augmented reality will
certainly gain from the web's so to
begin let's just start by getting
everyone on the same page and let's
define augmented reality so augmented
reality is the mixing of
computer-generated content with the real
world so to me the implication of that
is that we can now add contextualized
information into the world around us so
for example you're trying to make a
coffee and you're at the coffee machine
and now you have the instructions
overlaid on top of the coffee machine
and another implication of augmented
reality is that you can now interact
with 3d content in the 3d space so if
you're the canonical example would be
you're trying to buy a piece of
furniture and you're able to put it into
your room before you buy it so let's
look at what augmented reality looks
like today today this is smartphone AR
so this is run using a smartphone and it
basically has some understanding of the
world around it which allows virtual
content to interact with that world too
we also have augmented reality on
headsets so your hands would be free and
you'd be able to interact with the
content using your hands and a third
example that I think is less talked
about but I find really compelling is
audio based augmented reality so what
you're seeing there is bows frames and
it's pair of sunglasses that have
speakers they kind of shoot audio into
your ears and with that example so with
audio AR you would have that
you would have that experience where
you're at a coffee machine and you don't
know what to do but instead of seeing
the information it's read off to you I'd
also like to say if you hear me say AR
that's just short for augmented reality
so this talk as I mentioned it's also
about the web so let's talk about where
those two things intersect so that's
what we'll call them immersive web and
the immersive web is the use of
augmented reality virtual reality and
other 3d technologies on the web and so
it's this whole spectrum of things it
can be more augmented reality than
virtual reality and it doesn't quite
matter and you'll also hear me say X R
and that really just stands for wild
card reality so who could be virtual it
could be augmented reality and it could
be some combination of the two so today
what the immersive web looks like is
something like this we've seen
progressive enhancements of sites that
we use every day so on the left the left
two examples you'll see Facebook 3d
posts and they're incorporated directly
into the newsfeed so that first example
is a 3d model that you can interact with
on the newsfeed the second is using
portrait mode depth information to allow
you to delightfully play with these
photos with a bit of depth added and the
third example is from wikipedia who
about a year ago started supporting 3d
models in their articles so if you're
not a large company you don't have a
whole engineering team dedicated to
building this model viewing experience
there's a solution to that now so
recently Google a team at Google open
sourced a web component for viewing
models it's called model viewer it's
really fantastic and so using just HTML
you can add a model into your site
around it so that's an example using it
the astronaut which we all know and love
and something that's really great about
the mall viewer team is that they're
thinking about accessibility early so
they've already incorporated alt text
into the component
so let's say you have these 3d models on
your website how would you actually get
it into augmented reality so right now
what we've seen is implementations of
native system viewers that allow for
augmented reality so this is not running
in a web browser but there's this really
slick and tight integration with the web
so you would have this search result
so it's integrated into search with
Google so you can tap the button and
then it intents into this native viewer
and then you can place it in augmented
reality and the same thing exists on iOS
and it's similarly intense and so what I
just said there was that we're using
native viewers to do augmented reality
but at some point in the future we'd
probably like to do that in the browser
itself so that's where the WebEx our
device API would come in the web works
our device API exposes a low-level
sensor information so the camera pose if
you can place an object on the floor and
that's under development it's open so we
can all contribute to it and you can
find that on github and with those
examples that I just shared
that's all talking about bringing
immersive technologies into the web but
we can also bring the web into immersive
technologies so here are two examples of
XR browsers so on the Left you'll see
from magic leap the Helio browser and
they're placing web pages into the world
around you and on the other side you'll
see Firefox reality which is a VR
browser so I think the immersive web
today is fantastic I think it's adding
information it's making it more
delightful to browse the web but when
we're developing these technologies it's
important to see where we're going next
and to start thinking about that earlier
rather than later so when I think about
a future of augmented reality I start by
thinking about how can this assist me so
I think about maybe I'm leaving work one
day and I'm wearing these lightweight AR
toggles I'm walking down the street I'm
looking for dinner so as I look
the restaurants on the street I'm seeing
if Yelp data populating with the stars
rating and the types of menu and maybe I
also want to see photos of the food so
Instagram informations coming too and I
like Pokemon so maybe while I'm doing
all of this I'm also catching pokémon
playing Pokemon go and when I get to the
train station
I'll have information populated for me
telling me which train to take so that I
can get home fastest and as I mentioned
earlier I probably don't want to be
restricted to doing this on just one
headset maybe I want headphones another
day from a different company or who
knows and maybe I just want to use my
smartphone so when I'm thinking of this
vision of augmented reality going
forward I start to see some interesting
things and patterns that I'd like to
call out here so the first is that it
inherently uses web content I want
access to all the things that I already
used when I'm browsing the web another
thing is that we're it's this really
interesting composition of different
types of information so that could be
models it could be 2d pages and we're
gonna have to interact with them in a
way that's aesthetic and delightful and
still makes me want to use it and one
third trend that I start to see is that
we're really interacting with the world
around us so I could be placing
information onto a building or on a tree
or on passing by cars and so when I
start to think about this vision that I
want and where we are today which is
mostly placing 3d models I think there's
a lot of work to go and where I see a
lot of that work coming into play is
with a user agent so the definition from
w3c of a user agent is a user agent is
any software that retrieves renders and
facilitates end-user interaction with
web content so today that's usually just
your browser so you get a lot of things
when you're browsing using any of the
modern browsers so that could be Chrome
it could be Firefox it helps you do safe
browsing
renders the HTML pages for you and
things like that so to understand how a
user agent will play out with his added
dimension for augmented reality let's
start to break down this definition of
user agent so I'll go in reverse order
so let's start with a user agent
facilitates end-user interaction with
web content so what I believe is that
the user should always be in control of
how information is presented to them so
on a modern web browser that's
preferences like default text sizing
that's contrast ratios and Chrome
extensions and things like that but when
you think about augmented reality we
have this whole new dimension and it's
really immersive it's you know and so we
need to start thinking about other ways
that we want to have safe browsing and
we want the user to be in control so one
example would think about physical
proximity so you have content that's
being rendered possibly close to you and
I should be able to say I'm not
comfortable with anything rendering
closer than five meters away from me or
I also think it's compelling to think
about this in terms of sound I probably
would never want to allow someone to
whisper into my ear as I'm walking down
the street so a lot of these
considerations come into play when were
talking about augmented reality and in
order to accommodate these things for
the user we're gonna need an
intervention point for this information
so the user agent needs to know what's
being asked of it to incorporate this so
if we think about some declarative
content that we all know and love
that would be HTML and CSS and so I see
this future where there's declarative
content that you're able to add into the
world around you so you could specify
things like I would like float:left and
pin to a building or you could say I
want the depth to be five meters from
the user but it's up to the user agent
to decide whether or not it can actually
honor that request and it's in that way
that
can advocate for the user so another
thing that declarative content offers is
that it provides semantic understanding
for the user agent so what that means is
that the user agent actually has a view
into what's being asked to be rendered
or presented to the user so I find this
example extremely highlighting of what
I'm talking about that thing so if we
look at the left side we see WebGL
inspector ability so if you're just
given this canvas to render a 3d object
which is how it works on the web today
if you're given an XY location on there
you can only see the color so you could
say I see a black pixel I see a white
pixel a grey pixel but nothing more than
that
but with semantic understanding of
what's actually in the scene we have a
much more rich understanding of the
models in the content that we're placing
so if you look at the right side you can
see I'm looking at the windshield and it
has a material that's glass and it's
transparent you can also see things like
the tire and stuff like that and so you
can imagine with screen readers or
accessible or just translating this into
sound based AR you can actually talk
about what the user seeing so you could
say I see a van with black tires in
white car metal paint so the next part
of the user agent that I'll talk about
is rendering so the user agent is
responsible for rendering to the browser
so modern web rendering engines are
amazing they're fantastic that's blank
gecko WebKit and things like that when
you think about what there has to do
it's mostly 2d and it's text-based so
they're fantastic at rendering pages
like the verge at 60 frames per second
and some of you might know and some of
you might not but the web already does
do performant 3d rendering it's really
great and that's provided to you as the
user through a canvas element and then
it uses WebGL to actually create those
graphics and so what that might look
like on the web today is this
this is not augmented reality or virtual
reality but it's just rendering in a
webpage using a canvas in WebGL so for
the rendering needs of augmented reality
which if you think back to that vision
is this complex composition and layout
dynamics of content so we're going to
probably need to build a rendering
engine that can handle that from the
ground up whereas the modern rendering
engines were optimized for 2d and so
even though I just said that we probably
want this organized from the ground up
and that we don't want to use canvas
elements we tried it so my team
experimented on this internal prototype
that we call air webview an air webview
is a set of libraries that enable
web-based AR in native apps through
system web views so a system webview is
just a lightweight browser that you can
embed into native app and so the
technical understanding of what we've
done is that we have web rendered
virtual content so we're using a web
page to do that and we're compositing it
with native tracking so that's air core
and air kit and we combine that with a
natively rendered camera feed so let's
look at what that looks like so if you
look at this example we have a storm
trooper and it's convincingly rendered
into this space around you and so what
you need to do is you have to make sure
that the content that's rendered moves
at the same time as a native camera feed
because if it's off it completely breaks
the illusion so we have that transparent
webview it's rendering the content and
this actually becomes a very difficult
technical problem because if you're
familiar and don't worry if you're not
but so you have a render loop that's
running from the browser but then you
also have a render loop that's running
natively and you also have the update
loop for the native tracking so it's
figuring out a way to get all of these
things working together in a performant
way and the advantages of air webview is
that it's lightweight it's only 60
kilobytes to add it to your app it's
cross-platform so you write code once
and it works on both iOS and Android
it's embeddable into native apps and you
can pull down content and code on-demand
and that last part to highlight the
advantages of that is that you can make
changes to this augmented reality
experience that's independent from your
native app code so you don't have to
wait for an app release to change your
AR experience so one use of air webview
in action was at Google i/o this year so
if you were there you would have seen
this experience allowed you to orient
yourself in the once you're on site at
the conference and so using augmented
reality you could look around and see
which way you might want to go next and
so this experience is literally just a
web page and those white text let's say
water station eats market are actually
just HTML elements styled with 3d
transforms so again the air web view
it's a prototype
its internal we had a lot of fun and we
learned a lot with it so this last
aspect of the user agent that I'll talk
about is that the user agent retrieves
content on behalf of the user and this
part is so fascinating to me so if you
think back to this vision of augmented
reality you're walking down the street
and you look at a restaurant and it
knows what you want is the menu
information and it knows what you want
is the Instagram photos and so if I was
doing this today on my smartphone I
would go to the restaurant I would see
the name I would type it into maybe
Google search dr. Koh who knows and then
I would access the information that I
wanted but what we have with augmented
reality is this fundamental paradigm
shift so now the user agent is querying
on my behalf and it should know what I
want to see and that's very interesting
so in a camera first browsing
environment the user receives content
rather than querying for it and the
implication of that is that the user
agent gains discretion over content
surfacing and this is a very interesting
question right off the bat so we can
think about modern questions that we're
having about echo chambers and things
like
so imagine you're in an augmented
reality immersive world and you don't
know when there's content that you're
not seeing or you should just have a way
to know and you should have ways to set
preferences on what you do want to see
and I think that there is kind of this
pessimistic view of that but I also
think that there's a lot of advantages
of having this intermediary between you
and the information so an example that I
like to think of is imagine you're a
coffee drinker and you wake up you want
to wear your AR glasses on your way to
work but you haven't had your glass of
coffee so you just want the bare minimum
and until you get to that coffee shop
then you're ready to get all the other
things coming so in that way the user
agent having discretion is an advantage
and so as you start to hear these things
about augmented reality and maybe this
future where everybody's wearing
headsets you might be like me yesterday
and Conrad electric electronics thinking
that's a lot of cameras so it's true a
camera first future requires a lot of
cameras and it's not just augmented
reality that's facing these things it
would be things like self-driving cars
where they have six sensors eight
sensors a ton of sensors just sensing
the world around it as its continuing to
process and so if you think about what
that actually means is that we're now
capturing basically everything that
happens on the sidewalk anything that
someone wearing one of these headsets
can see and so as we try to build
towards this augmented reality future we
need to have privacy and surveillance
top of mind when thinking about world
scale they are so at face value I think
one of the first things you'd think
about in the context of privacy is that
these cameras are capturing RGB data
about the world around you which is just
a picture so what happens with that
picture data is your device computing it
on device is it going up to a cloud who
owns that data on the cloud is it going
to your private cloud and then when you
think about secondary data so that's
information that six
directed from this camera image which is
how augmented reality works you can
imagine that if you're building up
meshes around you let's say you're
someone that lives in an apartment
building with a very distinct statue
outside and so you walk out your headset
create some mesh of this statue then
someone could know that exactly where
that statue is and then locate you so
even if they don't have the camera data
they can understand that from the
derivative information that's used for
augmented reality and what I think
though is that user user agents being
more powerful it's actually an advantage
in this scenario because if we can move
that information away from the developer
and closer to a trusted user agent
that's a positive thing but we'll need
something like open source code to
actually know that we're being that we
can trust our user agents so to me
augmented reality and the web is an
amazing partnership the web will gain a
whole new access for understanding
information it'll be more contextualized
it'll be economic and for augmented
reality the web for sure is an important
piece it provides the content and I love
the web' principles that we use to
develop today and so I think that as we
look forward to a future with augmented
reality we need to keep those webby
principles in mind and if you're
interested in using and leveraging the
immersive web today you should go back
and check out some of those resources I
mentioned so you should look at the
model viewer and see if adding 3d models
increases use and context to your
information and also start talking to us
about the WebEx or device API everyone's
in from opinion matters and it'll be
great for the ecosystem overall so to me
if the web plus augmented reality is an
open ecosystem of rich contextualized
information than I'm excited and I hope
that URL r2
[Music]